2026년 4월 24일 금요일 미국 증시 요약입니다.
금요일 미국 증시는 상승 마감했습니다.
미국과 이란 간의 협상 재개에 기대감이 커지며 증시는 사상 최고치로 치솟았습니다.
여기에 인텔의 깜짝 실적과 파월 연준 의장의 사법 리스크 해소 소식이 전해지며 지수 상승을 견인했습니다.
특히 파월 의장에 대한 수사 종결로 차기 연준 의장으로 지명된 케빈 워시의 인중 가설이 커지자 금리 인하에 대한 시장 기대감이 높아졌고 이는 미 국제금리 하락으로 이어졌습니다.
백악관 대변인은 퍽시 뉴스에서 스티브 위커프 특사와 제로드 쿠슈너가 주말 사이 이란과의 회담을 위해 파키스탄을 향한다고 밝혔습니다.
뉴욕 타임즈 역시 이란 외무장관이 미국 대표단과 만나 평화협상안에 대한 서면 답변이었습니다.
이는 이란과의 회담을 위해 파키스탄을 향한 서면 답변을 전달할 예정이라고 보도했습니다.
다만 이란 타스님 통신은 이를 부인하며 이란 당국이 미국과의 협상협에 대해 아직 어떠한 결정도 내리지 않은 상태라고 선을 그었습니다.
이러한 지적적 불확실성에도 불구하고 견조한 기업 실적과 전반적인 탄탄한 경제 여건이 증시에 든든한 버팀목 역할을 하고 있습니다.
이날 S&P 오브지 수는 1% 가까이 상승하며 2024년 이후 최장기 주간열쇠입니다.
이번 엘리의 주역은 단연 인텔이었습니다.
인텔 주가는 23.6% 폭등하며 1987년 10월 이후 최대 1위 상승률을 기록했고 이는 반도체 섹터 전반의 강세로 이어졌습니다.
덕분에 필라델피아 반도체 지수는 18거래일 연속 상승이라는 전례없는 기록을 세웠습니다.
이제 시장의 시선은 다음주로 쏠리고 있습니다.
아마존, 구글, 메타, 마이크로소프트, 애플 등 5개의 빅테크 기업의 실적 발표가 대거 예정되어 있습니다.
에드워드 존스의 안젤로 쿠르카파스는
탄탄한 실적 성장이 뒷받침되면서 시장이 지적적 리스크나 유가 변동성에 내성을 갖게 된 것으로 보인다.
인터랙티브 브로커스의 호세 토레스는
인텔의 압도적인 분기 실적은
반도체 섹터의 역사적 랠리를 연장시키는 동기입니다.
동시에 AR 혁명이 여전히 폭발적인 성장 잠재력을 품고 있다는 확신을 심어주고 있다 라고 전하였습니다.